MARK MIRCHANDANI:
On this episode,
we talk to doc.ai about
how large health care
companies can start to gain
the benefits of running
in the cloud.
[THEME MUSIC]
So how has the
cloud kind of been
a catalyst to making this change
in the industry as a whole?
AKSHAY SHARMA: Yeah,
it's a great question.
So if you look
at, traditionally,
most big health
care-related companies
are not really on the cloud.
They're usually on
their own data centers.
Moving to cloud has
many challenges,
so one is regulatory and
compliance challenge.
We are seeing that most
cloud providers today
are HIPAA compliant out
of the box, which reduces
the sort of barrier to entry.
But it's still
pretty hard for them
to move massive amounts of
data to cloud because there
is cost associated with it.
But the stickiness
aspect with the cloud
is that you don't have to
build tools from the ground up,
because there are so many
services out of the box
that the cloud offers that it
makes valuable because it's
a question of opportunity cost.
Can you get to market sooner?
However, still there are enough
challenges for big health care
players to be on the cloud.
What we are seeing
at doc.ai startups--
which is a startup, basically--
we don't have that issue.
We can be on cloud.
We are cloud-native from get-go.
So we want it to be
scalable, resilient, and use
all the services out
of the box so that we
can get to market sooner.
What we have seen is
we were able to get
to market significantly
faster, not
having to worry about
infrastructure or managing
servers, and use the
plethora of services
that Google Cloud provides.
A great example of that is
Google Kubernetes Engine,
and along with all
the other containers
that we can easily roll out
and other type of services,
like SDL Proxy and so on, which
makes it really easy for us
to not have a big infrastructure
and dev ops team, but focus
on rolling back
product features.
So it's been great that
way to be on the cloud.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
And that makes sense
for startups, who, you know,
they want to be a cloud native,
they need to get
to market sooner.
It's really easy to be
agile when you're small.
What would you say the
most important kind
of cloud technologies or
cloud-related resources
are available to larger
companies that can help them
adopt a similar methodology?
AKSHAY SHARMA: That's
a great question.
So I think it's a multi-phase
approach for bigger companies
that are not on cloud already.
So what I suggest is that any
of the new products and services
that you want to
roll out, you want
to consider being
on the cloud first.
So some principles
of being cloud-native
means that you can use some
of the open source technology
so that you're not necessarily
locked into one cloud vendor,
and you have the optionality
of being able to run that back
on your data center.
So the first suggestion
from my point of view
is that you start building new
services and products as sort
of a cloud-native version
that can run on any cloud,
including your own data center.
Second phase of
that would be, how
do you sort of bring
other interesting data
that you sit on in
your own data centers
and use that in conjunction
with the data that's
being collected on your
new services and products?
So you could bring your
own data to the cloud
or you could sink the data back
from the cloud to your own data
centers, where you are now
building a much more robust set
of models or services.
But over time, as
phase three, I would
say that you may
want to consider
moving a lot of your
computational needs
onto the cloud.
The challenge with
that is at scale,
cloud becomes pretty expensive.
An example of that
would be if you're
building a lot of
interesting models
that require a lot of GPU
computational resources,
then these are pretty
expensive on a per hour basis.
So it's still very valuable
to consider moving to a cloud,
but then build it and
design it in a way
that you're not tied
to a specific cloud.
And there are many open
source tools and technologies
that let you do
that so, that way,
you can bring it back to your
own data center eventually.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Yeah,
and a hybrid approach
is still something that's
not only relatable,
but actually really
desirable to a lot of people.
So how does that relate to the
cloud being more expensive?
AKSHAY SHARMA: Right, so
it depends on where you
are in the company's journey.
So a big established
company may have already
owned the real estate for
having their own data centers.
So the marginal cost
of adding the server
would still look far
more lucrative for them
to move to cloud, as
opposed to move to cloud.
But what I see is
that there is going
to be an explosion of
different tools and services,
and especially new type of
computation environments
that you can get.
For example, you're seeing
PPUs that Google is pioneering
and rolling out.
It'll almost be
impossible to bring those
to back to your data centers.
So in some way, you're
right that it's better
to be on cloud, because you
can manage costs certainly
in some way because you
only use it in on demand.
But then with already at
scale, certain companies
find it easier and cheaper
to roll out new machines,
but not necessarily offering
the same capabilities.
It's an opportunity cost of
the future versus marginal cost
of the present day,
that these big companies
have to make a trade-off.
The initial cost will
be higher on the cloud,
simply because to replicate
the same level of computational
resources, it's going
to be expensive.
But with the right sort of teams
and right infrastructure teams
in place, where you're
not spending up resources
and wasting it away,
you can somehow
have a handle on the cloud.
But I think really
it's the future
of where your
products can go, which
I think is only possible being
on a cloud provider today.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Stay tuned for
more conversations with doc.ai.
If you enjoyed this episode,
check out the "Stack Chat"
playlist for more great videos.
[CLOSING THEME]